yes oh that's a I think there's one
question that everyone asks it's the
first question that everybody asks about
the violent and it is it scripted and
it's not at all which I think surprises
a lot of people zero structure okay so
okay what they say is is it scripted and
I think a lot of the reasons for that
are when you take a normal conversation
normal discourse day-to-day and you put
like a Justin Bieber song in the
background and like have a drone flying
around or like some cool music and a
camera floats around on the boom arm
when you chop it up cleverly you the
whole point is to make it seem cohesive
right it's to make these people that are
on the show seem cool and aspirational
and interesting to watch and engaging by
virtue that you has to look polished
which I think can lead to people
thinking that's contrived in an bollocks
which isn't true it's not scripted
however there are what's called villa
producers and these are the point of
contact between the cast's the primary
point of contact between the cast and
the production team and what they'll do
is they'll come into the villa into the
garden which is usually where everybody
is and just take people off to one side
to having it so meaning you've had an
argument because both of us like Yusef
and it's the trials as much it is it's I
can't believe the first time that we
videoed a podcast you decided to wear
your sari gone we the first podcast we
ever recorded he wore bright green
trousers you've still got those I still
have I wasn't the other day you promise
me you won't listen I promise I've burn
the green high tops so I mean I'm just I
just [ __ ] despaired only um anyway
what was I saying what was that scene
that's you one chance to pick that glass
I know goes back on the carpet it was
back on the carpet
um yeah so the other producers they come
in and mean you have an argument about
the fact that we like you sir
and what she'll do is she'll come over
and she'll say Oh Julie how do you how
do you feel about - about you Charlie
you just had with Chris oh well you know
like I'm a little bit worried because I
thought me and you if we're going to get
it on but it's turned out that he
actually likes Chris instead now and I'm
feeling a bit with what I think you
should do maybe grab you surf go off the
far side have a little chat with him and
then you go over are you touching your
boobs whoa you are you are you're used
to audio only
and we've got video today you did self
dropping I mean well you just immune on
me so and then say go the far side and
have a chat but when you go over the far
side you will see like this setup
shitloads or an army of cameramen
outside of the boundary of the house or
pointing in your direction right so they
don't the show is not scripted
what is the restructure yeah absolutely
if the thing that everybody needs to
remember when they're watching the
violent is that there's only 24 hours in
a day and if you produce any content as
a cast member as a Islander as it's
called up until 4:00 a.m. ish the next
night at a pier that
edited and be on TV how many editors do
they have they must have a team so we
there's a whole bunch of things that are
surprising about it probably one of the
most surprising things was there the
villa that we were in I think it's a
different Villa now I haven't watched
season three so I'm not sure the villa
that we were in was very very nice and
had the largest natural water pool in
all of Europe was huge is massive so I
was it like it was absolutely huge any
was saltwater as well so it was just
crazy this millionaire French guy French
investors house at Villa and he had the
exact same Villa brick for brick in
France so you should wear never the
exact same one this things the same get
the same layout the same masonry work if
you just a command a and select all come
on see my man V yeah return its
worthless when you're trying to throw it
down it needs to all be green don't
spout the formatting then don't know
when you're copying it over and it'll be
it like have the layout if any of its
read and you can tell anyway yeah you
have to have from the left a rogue like
book book oh boy I've never enough for
what you wouldn't run out of funds
because you'd make a rich
so we go out of the villa sometimes I
get to that in a second when we went out
of the villa it looked like Basra yeah
there is rolls and this is without
exaggeration a hundred industrial unit
corrugated iron like what you'd see on
shipping containers on the back of these
huge freighters they're coming over and
in there's four in a row production
office all with huge air-conditioning
units on the back two in a row Caroline
flax changing room five in a circle task
team the guys that do the challenges
like it's wood workshop and all the rest
of and all of these have just been
shipped over and you go out and you have
no you're just this tiny little gnat
like doing just going I fancied a bird
and and you go out and just like [ __ ]
hell this it is hunting actually it's a
very you know you gotta do that sci-fi
horror kind of
sinara just realized how much how much
of a bastard that operation is it is and
this was the first one and it's got
exponentially bigger so season one was
probably a quarter as popular as season
two which is probably a quarter as
popular as season three so I can only
imagine that that level of extremity has
been taken third so yeah you go out I
didn't so the number of produces and and
you feel like you're living in a
simulation yet like what you did about
the Truman Show isn't it where
everything's engineer like conversations
are engineered the environments
engineering everyone's watching
everything that you're doing yeah I mean
the first time I went outside and
couldn't believe just how many of these
things are there's a full on-site
canteen they've got bus drivers working
on a rotation 24 hours a day shipping
people from the accommodation where
they've bought a whole hotel for like
two and a half months while watches for
the team just for the team just for the
production team they've got like a team
of sixty security who are on rotation at
all times around the villa around the
villa but also just around the
production place right and they're
checking in at the top like booboo we've
got a gray Ford Mondeo just driving down
the hill John can you look I know no
worries me no worry that's just the
Domino's guy again for John so yeah is
it scripted no it's not and but do they
poke the storylines yeah they definitely
do there has to be a narrative like a
nothing editing you can create any
narrative you want from quite small
amount of data which I guess is why you
know with politicians they so you know
the Ed Miliband video that was going
round where it looked like he was just
psychotic because he just kept repeating
weird phrases and it's become a bit it's
because they just someone uploaded the
entire take of five minutes but he knows
that he's going to get chopped into
twenty seconds or something so he has to
keep repeating so then when I said it in
45 different ways yeah actually got it
right well the water on the rhetoric put
it aside get on to the negotiating table
and come together and then just keep
iteration of that
Yeah right why mean one of the things
that you can't do which actually sucks a
little bit is there's no second takes
and if it's scripted there would be I
mean you can't do stuff thank you don't
get a second chance to say the same
thing to people in terms of an
impression and that means that the
reaction can't be contrived but the guys
that are going on here the guys that do
Joey show the 16 seasons deep they
probably could have had sufficient media
training to actually be able to fake a
response you've picked [ __ ] Stephanie
18 hairdresser from Wigan and dropped
her in the middle of me author and said
right Stephanie we just gonna have to
take that again can you just do the same
reaction please your heads going yeah
yeah so that's so it's all first time
there's no nothing ever gets done again
so the challenges that they do move
those challenges to win dates and stuff
like that those do get second takes that
much more highly produced and the dates
are as well right one of the reasons for
that is that in the villa
you've got controlled camera setups
we've come in today and we've done this
is the first time that were videoing
something in here it's the first time
that the guys there they're recording it
of how to come in and set up and the
longest amount of time of anything was
set up way through to come in and do it
again
it would be boom drop straight in so
little known fact about love island on
the week before we went in on season 1
they did an entire six day dry run with
a whole separate cast exactly the same
purely so that they could get the camera
angles in the lighting right well just
so they don't have to do all that while
you're less so there was a pair of
Italian twins they're coming online like
season 2 or season three or something
like that
I did three episodes here so three are
okay and they had a different pair of
twins so everything is the same the same
storylines Jess Hays who's the girl that
won mm-hmm was in the dry run and was
producing such good content during that
that they said right pull her out
get a put her in the main one next week
and there's a girl called Naomi who was
the one that actually got quite a bit of
backlash is that fern fit blonde one and
she was supposed to go in at the start
and they were like she ended up being
what just waiting in the orchid for like
two and a half weeks ready for her to go
in because she'd been like slipstream by
this girl who'd been proven to be
interesting but one of the other things